alors de quoi s'agit-il quand on parle
d'un accord de réparation snc lavalin
aurait-elle dû en profiter
la ministre de la justice procureur
général n'a pas donné son aval à cette
alternative judiciaire pour tenter de
mieux comprendre je n'ai plus quoi être
professeur en droit de l'université
d'ottawa experte en responsabilité
pénale des entreprises pour sa part d'un
collègue
bon sang de bonsoir madame on vous a mis
dans certaines de reportages et j'ai lu
un texte de vous il ya différents points
de vue ici sur la qualification possible
ou non decency lavalin à ce fameux
accord de réparation et dispositions
nouvelles au code criminel des
cimetières de mesures alternatives pour
éviter un procès selon vous est-ce que
c'est lavalin aurait dû se qualifier
pour un accord de réparation c'est
difficile de répondre à cette question
là de façon nette
oui ou non parce qu en fait
contrairement à ce que certains ont
laissé entendre qu'on a à revendre on
rencontre les conditions donc on devrait
avoir été invité c'est pas si simple
parce que les critères évalués implique
nécessairement de porter un regard sur
l'ensemble des circonstances pour
arriver à une conclusion ce que oui ou
non c'est dans l'intérêt public et s'est
approprié dans les circonstances
et en fait dans la loi on identifie huit
facteurs en sus d'avoir une sorte de
neuvième facteurs et tout autre facteur
pertinent qui vont qui alimentent cette
analyse
alors c'est pas une question de
simplement dire bon on coche quatre
boîtes et là c'est bon on qualifie alors
la question quelle source de profit que
vous avez justement pour dire que snc
lavalin pour et aux postes qualifiés
bon ben les gros qui cadrent un peu avec
les objectifs plus grande du régime sait
dans quelles circonstances est ce qu'on
a appris les informations sur la
commission de l'infraction est ce que
c'est une dénonciation est ce que c'est
quelqu'un de l'entreprise qui est venu
dénoncer son entreprise où l'entreprise
même est-ce que c'est par là la suite
d'une enquête policière par exemple ou
peut-être de la coopération
internationale avec d'autres autorités
dans d'autres pays c'est ça sa colonie
la perception de la chose
une autre un autre facteur bien sûr
c'est celle impact sur d'autres parties
prenantes donc est ce que est ce qu'il
ya des catégories de personnes qui
risquent de subir des conséquences et
lesquelles
et quelle est l'ampleur donc on peut
penser aux employés à ceux qui
bénéficient d'un régime de pension les
actionnaires ceci dit la qualification
qui sont tous innocents je pense qu a
besoin de nuances mais on pourra voir
plus tard avec ça un autre élément qui
est très important et sur lequel régime
est calqué c est ce qu il ya de la
coopération est ce que est ce que on a
fourni de l'aide aux enquêteurs une des
idées derrière le régime d'accord de
réparation et un des raisonnements qu'on
offre pour le justifier
c'est de dire on va découvrir des choses
qu'on n'aurait pas pu découvrir parce
que la nature même des crimes
économiques c'est qu'ils sont difficiles
à déceler et voilà oui d'ailleurs les
pénalités d'ailleurs l'entreprise qui
signent un accord de réparation sauvage
ce n'est pas de précédent au canada
encore là mais doit payer une somme
importante
oui je signalerai toutefois que les
nouveaux vous invitez précédents ont au
moins fait mention du caractère un peu
les punit punitif financiers mon fils
moi je verrais plus l'accord de
réparation dans une lumière de
réhabilitation parce que je pense que
l'élément le plus important est le
facteur le plus important qu'ils jouent
en faveur de snc lavalin
c est ce que on a pris les mesures pour
changer l'environnement la culture de
l'organisation et de faire en sorte que
ça ne survient plus il met la question
ouverte que j'ai et j'ouvre une
parenthèse dossier on a toujours dit ces
quelques personnes
il ya des milliers de personnes qui vont
payer pour les erreurs de quelques
personnes mais là ça c'est une question
à mon avis je suis pas encore satisfaite
que s'il est simplement une question de
pommes pourries est-ce qu'on n'a pas
aussi à s'interroger sur le nombre de
fois qu'il y à des suggestions qu'ils
aient eu des problèmes à ce moment là on
peut se demander que ce peut-être c'est
aussi structurel ou organisationnelles
quelque chose dont je me semble en tout
cas que c'était lavalin on l'a dit
pour ceux qui s'y connaissent en
affaires 10b ce n'est plus la même
entreprise vous avez entendu monsieur
legault vous avez entendu le ministre du
québec
est ce qu'on peut se demander qu'est ce
que monsieur trou d'où vous le dire en
dix ans on a fait de travail on a
respecté toutes les normes dans la
mesure où peut-être que d'introduire cet
accord de réparation là dedans un coq
trimestre comme un choix politique comme
et pas de précédent après si on demande
au système judiciaire de l'exécuter
ouais la difficulté c'est que la
résolution d'affaires pénales dans notre
système tel qu'il est conçu et tel qu'il
fonctionne relève du procureur et on
insiste en quelque sorte sur
l'indépendance des procureurs l'or qui
lorsqu'ils prennent des décisions par
rapport à comment régler des dossiers
que ce soit des affaires qui implique
des individus ou des entreprises et pour
une bonne raison parce qu'on voudrait
que c'est ces affaires-là soit réglée en
fonction des critères d'intérêt public
et du respect des principes de droit
pénal et donc et pas des considérations
politiques
alors je conviens que les procureurs ne
vivent pas dans des bulles
ils sont conscients des enjeux mais je
pense que c'est si la difficulté c'est
que l'accord de réparation est quelque
chose qui s'intègre dans la discrétion
du procureur et c'est comme ça ça a vu
le jour
le pays qui l'a utilisé depuis le plus
longtemps
c'est les états unis et ça a évolué
comme une forme d'exercice de discrétion
du procureur en fait aux états unis est
assujettie à aucun surveillance comme on
envisage au canada avec un tribunal donc
c'est vraiment la nature même de la
chose que ce qu'ils méritent indique
composants de discrétion là dedans en
terminale vers une seconde c'est pas des
sûrement un passe droit pour
l'entreprise qui ont un accord de
réparation non pas du tout et ça serait
à 2 min le but de du régime de dire que
c'est automatique
à ce moment là ils s'encouragent pas les
entreprises à se conformer à la loi à la
loi même je te fâche les ramadans quoi
merci infiniment
on va suivre ça de toute une tempête
avoir là dessus
merci et oui et oui merci merci à vous
pour voir